first Google and then tonight open AI
both companies have released fun useful
and pretty impressive tools that can see
what you see listen and even browse
alongside you Google is free open AI is
paid but open AI have included parts of
their tool in iPhone 16s I'm going to
give you just my highlights from the
literally dozens of announcements in
just the last 24 hours we'll take a one
or 2 minute demo to tour and then I'll
give you a hint about why these models
make more mistakes than you might think
plus of course some benchmarks can't
resist that now I could save the best
till last but I won't I'm just going to
give you the coolest tool in my opinion
straight up front you can access it for
free at AI studio.
google.com/ we're going to have a
conversation with Gemini 2.0 from Google
deepmind I'm not going to say it's their
smartest model and I'll get back to that
later but it is their newest just for a
brief moment though let's not care tooo
much about the smartness of the model
look at what you can do if you're on
mobile what you'll want to do is Click
show Gemini and then it can gain
permission to look out of your camera
now you could already send videos to
Gemini but this is live interaction
maybe ask it about that building you're
walking by or that plant you can see
next to the path because we're using
this for entertainment and curiosity I
don't mind too much that it makes the
occasional mistake obviously do not rely
on the answers I'm going to click share
screen in just a moment but first I have
to give you a bit of context here is
another tool announced by Google
yesterday called Deep research and it's
only available via Gemini Advanced it's
a decent tool it researches the web
collates from like 20 results and
presents them to you I asked tell me
everything about simple bench featured
on AI explained and it gave me a plan
and then I approved it by saying start
research and it gave me this result it's
definitely comprehensive research but
you can't really rely on it as
exemplified by this sentence now though
let's investigate that interactively
with Gemini this is free so bear that in
mind okay share your screen and then
pick the screen you want hi Gemini how
are you I am doing great thanks for
asking how are you today I'm good can
you read out the sentence highlighted in
yellow of course the highlighted
sentence reads llama 3.1 outperformed
other models like GPT 4 Turbo Gemini 1
.5 Pro and Claude 3.5 Sonet on the
simple Bench close but good enough now
can you look at the leaderboard and tell
me is that correct yes that's correct
the leaderboard shows that llama 3.1
405b instruct is in eighth place with a
score of 23% while the first place is 01
preview with a score of
41.7% this is honestly really fun to
speak to you and you sound like a cool
dude but did did llama 3.1 really
outperform Claude 3.5 Sonic which I'm
going to highlight you are are correct
it seems that llama 3 one did not
outperform Claude 3.5 sonnet as Claude
3.5 Sonet is ranked second with a score
of
41.4% while llama 3.1 is ranked eighth
with a score of 23% thank you for your
honesty Gemini by the way this is the
channel that came up with simple bench
any feedback on the Aesthetics of the
thumbnails sure the AI explains Channel
on YouTube has a consistent Style with
its thumbnails they typically use a
combination of text and images and they
have a very clear and legible text
overlay the colors are bright and
contrasting which makes the thumbnail
stand out thank you very much Gemini of
course you will have noticed some basic
mistakes there because even though this
is Gemini 2.0 Flash the whole new Gemini
2 era actually Gemini 2 flash got around
20% on simple bench simple bench is all
about testing basic reasoning and seeing
the question behind the question
question other new entrance include
llama 3.3 at
19.9% and Gemini experimental
interestingly
31.1% that's not the model that powers
that interaction why then did Google
pick Gemini 2 flash for this tool well
because it's much cheaper and faster
some of you who have been following the
announcements will say but wait Phillip
I thought Gemini 2 flash got crazy
results in all the benchmarks well yes
it got crazy results in all the
benchmarks they picked to show you
notice also they only compared the
results to their own models 01 for
example let alone 01 Pro gets close to
20 points higher on this Benchmark for
example testing biology physics
chemistry but In fairness to Google they
aren't really pretending like Gemini 2.0
flash is the best model around perhaps
they learned their lesson from one of
their previous releases where demisa
sais said I think it was Gemini 1.5 Pro
is now better than experts in a range of
subjects scoring highly on certain tests
doesn't mean for now that you can match
the breadth of human expertise luckily
then hassabis didn't make that claim
this time around but there are other
things that Gemini 2 flash can do it can
speak in Whispers and different tones
and swap between languages
[Music]
it can also output and kind of edit
images and more on why I say kind of in
a moment we brought this image into AI
studio and sent it to the new
experimental Gemini 2.0 flash model this
is a realtime screen capture and all the
prompts you'll see in this video are
things that early testers can now try
and this is the entire prompt we gave it
turn this car into a convertible here
they are side by side actually I was
fortunate enough to get early access to
that tool and even though I can't show
you any of the results I can say it's
still a work in progress others though
have shown that you can upload an image
like this one of a Tic-Tac toe or nson
crosses board and ask its X turn to play
what should the next move be I must say
as anyone who has seen this channel
before will know I am quite the expert
at Tic-tac-toe and so I would agree when
Gemini 2 flash says the movie should be
this one and then it gives us the image
that's pretty cool one more cool thing
that Gemini 2 flash can do before we get
to a pretty big caveat Google demoed
project Mariner where Gemini 2 actually
takes over your computer well at least
it can click things browse the web and
perform actions even purchase things not
yet available mind you but I am trying
to get access here is a 20se second demo
you can ask it to do things like this
that require multiple steps doing
research to look up the artist
then finding the painting and then
shopping for the right supplies the
agent uses the web to take action and
find what you're looking
for it plans and reasons at each step
always staying in your control and
completing your
task Google Deep Mind are not the first
company to allow a model to take over
your device but the reason I didn't talk
about computer use from anthropic
powered by Claude at the time was
because it just really wasn't very good
I tried to get it to do countless things
and it simply couldn't it took ages and
rarely could achieve the goal but just
as an aside bear in mind this Benchmark
called Web Voyager testing how you can
navigate the web with visual inputs
clawed computer use gets 52% this
particular agent scaffold got 67% almost
project marinina as you could see
powered by Gemini 2 flash
90.5% with tree sege and in an interview
released just 3 hours ago I picked out
this this highlight spoken by Oriel
vigal he is the technical lead on Gemini
and will tell you what's coming soon I
could ask a Model A language model or
visual language model to learn to play
the game at of Starcraft that's a very
different approach to say create one
agent that does play the game in this
other example right it could go online
watch videos about the game it could uh
of course download the game to start
interacting with it to learn oh yeah
like I know how to you know I get it um
do research online go to forums read the
forums um go play and and figure out
that it's weak at this thing and improve
and so on and after literally it could
be weeks it sends you an email it says I
now know how to play the game Let's Play
right that's not a reality that's that
far away frankly that's quite enough
Buzz time to bring us all back down to
earth progress according to Google's own
CEO might be slowing down in his words
the the lwh hanging through is gone the
current generation of llm models are
roughly you know few companies have
converged at the top but I think we're
all working on our next versions too I
think the progress is going to get
harder when I look at 25 the low hanging
fruit is gone you know the the curve uh
the the hill is steeper you think it's
slowing down though so that's
interesting because I will tell you that
that your your competitor peer uh in Sam
Alman said there is no wall there is no
wall you you think it's it's maybe
slowing down in terms of how quickly it
scales I I'm very confident there'll be
a lot of progress in 25 okay right I
think the models are definitely going to
get better at at reasoning completing a
sequence of actions more reliably uh you
know more agentic if you will that is a
pretty STK contrast with what Sam wman
said as the CEO of open AI when he said
quote there is no wall end quote or
Dario amade the CEO of anthropic who
predicted transformative AI by 2026
that's AI that can automate whole SES of
the economy you can let me know in the
comments who you think is right in just
a few moments of course I will get to
the announcements from open AI over the
last couple of days but there's one
model that we have right now forget the
future it comes from the sponsor of
today's video assembly Ai and it's their
Universal 2 Speech to Text model I've
shown you plenty of comparisons before
on the channel but here's another few
for example proper nouns naturally
models have to get better at
understanding what you said before they
can get better at replying intelligently
links in the description some people
criticize me for being too harsh on open
Ai and do check out my previous video
for more of what I think but I will say
they are great at smooth interfaces you
could almost say apple like ux so
appropriately chat gbt is now inside
iPhone 16 yes that means it's inside
Apple intelligence but it's made by open
AI anyway no getting an iPhone 16 isn't
a way to circumvent paying for Plus or
Pro because even though you do get chat
gbt Vision it can as of yet only analyze
an image from within a video not like a
live interaction that's something
separate still cool though because you
can invoke chat GPT even if you don't
have a chat GPT account so I can imagine
hundreds of millions of quote normies
using this even though they don't follow
AI but for true video interaction
available in advanced voice mode you'll
need to get Plus or Pro that's $20 or
$200 a month respectively and though
it's not free just as with Google AI
Studio you got to admit it's a pretty
compelling tool sure I'm ready for a
quiz all right what what was the name of
my colleague that was wearing the
reindeer
antlers that would be
Michelle all right and how about the
name of my colleague that was wearing
the Santa hat
that would be Rowan all right good work
you're two for two you get an A thanks
Chad frankly I think this is the best of
AI where you don't always care too much
about super accurate answers but
satisfying your curiosity as of tonight
you can even speak to Santa via voice
mode and ask terribly rude questions
again as with Google you will find the
underlying intelligence of the model
you're using isn't the very best the
vision and advanced voice mode is based
on GPT 40 announced quite a while back
obviously that makes sense they just
don't have the gpus to give everyone the
best model at all times interactively
Gemini 2 flash is for us currently
heavily rate limited so we're struggling
to get the five runs necessary to
calculate an average but on the runs
we've done so far it scored around 20%
when the API does become available I do
expect o01 promo to sit comfortably at
the top of this leaderboard I should say
at the top of the models not above of
the human Baseline that Baseline 01 Pro
mode at least will not be so those were
my highlights from the dozens and dozens
that came out over the last 24 hours AI
models that can see what you see listen
browse alongside you even play games
alongside you actually that gets me
thinking I can imagine in like 2 3 years
kids or even adults when they're losing
a game online being like you're using
Gemini 4 Man actually that could be a
pretty serious problem for competitive
gameplay unless you had like land
tournaments anyway I'm getting too
distracted those were the announcements
I found the most interesting let me know
which ones you found the most compelling
and as always have a very wonderful day